telling us what He intends to do Hillary
Clinton and you'll see my connection
here Hillary Clinton went on The View
this week and you're not going to
believe who she compared Donald Trump to
people would get legitimately
elected and then they would try to do
away with elections and do away with
opposition and do away with a free press
and you could see it in countries where
well Hitler was duly elected right right
and so all of a sudden somebody with
those Tendencies though dictatorial
authoritarian Tendencies would be like
okay we're going to shut this down we're
going to throw these people in jail and
and they didn't usually Telegraph that
Trump is telling us what He intends to
do how about what Trump did uh because
he did not do away with a free press he
fought a free press all the time uh he
did not do away with elections he's not
the president as far as I know Ian this
this insanity this it's so damn
unfortunate because now when we have
people behaving like the Nazis going
after Jewish shops as you mentioned and
all of the other stuff uh the words
don't even have any meaning anymore yeah
I mean like two things one zalinski is
actually doing all of these things and
she's presumably still a massive fan of
Ukraine so I'm not to uh too sure she
actually cares about fascism or any of
these things but also if you just look
at the Nazi analogy as we've talked
about know during this show there are
actual Nazis on the streets now
screaming for the same thing that Nazis
wanted outside the Sydney Opera House
for example people were literally
screaming gas the Jews you see Pro
Palestinian people holding up swers um
painting swastikas on Jewish students
doors like Nazis are here they just
don't happen to be uh White in this case
and they don't happen to be um part of
the political narrative that people like
Hillary Clinton want to push and so it
doesn't count uh and also if you look at
really the safety of Jews if that's
going to be the metric we use to measure
the level of Nazism in the world then uh
the world was a much safer Jew place for
Jews under Donald Trump than it was
under Barack Obama and certainly under
Joe Biden so the the Hitler analogy is
obviously stupid but it's incredibly
dangerous when we have people who are on
the streets right now cheering for
Hitler it's just unbelievable CJ is this
the great trick the Democrats do all the
time it's like we all see what's
happening on the streets we hear the
chance everything that Ian just
referenced right there but then they can
get someone like Hillary to go on
mainstream media and then say Hitler in
a way that for all the liberals who are
breaking right now and we we know it's
happening right now a lot of Liberals
are kind of waking up right now they
suddenly hear that and then they
immediately go back the wrong way
because of that very tactic you're
exactly right you know the same uh you
know Playbook that they run you know
towards Jewish Americans the same
Playbook they've always ran towards
black Americans they compare every
single conservative to a white
supremacist to a Clansman to uh you know
some terrible terrible like you know
white supremacists or Nazi and it's it's
the only thing that they know how to do
they the only thing that they know the
only way they know how to win is by by
pitting white people against black
people Jews against you know everyone
else and that because identity politics
is all they have to run on they can't
run on the economy they can't run on
education they can't run on Public
Safety so they run on this just absolute
just demagoguery which is absolutely
disgusting and yeah Ian's point I
thought she was talking about zalinski
for that entire little thing until she
set Donald Trump at the end considering
he is literally now saying that there
shouldn't be an election he also
Consolidated all of the media into one
statun media entity everything that she
just said is literally what zalinski is
doing but of course no criticism of him
from her I wouldn't expect that um but
again to your point all these
anti-semitic attacks that we're seeing
in the country right now are not being
waged by people wearing Maga hats no
what we're seeing are people who are big
supporters of folks like former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton big
supporters um of progressive politicians
like Rashida Talib Alan Omar these are
people who are not trying to conceal who
they are in any which way they are
calling for the extermination of the
Jewish people they are chanting from The
River To The Sea they are siding with
Hamas and it's so crazy to kind of say
that out loud sometimes because it's
like oh because it's one thing to side
with Democrats it's one thing toci side
with Republicans siding with Hamas
should have some weight to it when you
say it because they are literal
terrorists imagine if a few years ago we
were going around saying that people
were siding with Isis those people would
be excommunicated from societ
for very good reason it is not it's just
not a moral sance to have in any which
way